sources tell our 8 news now
investigators that this particular
police shooting is connected to a murder
that happened earlier today you can see
behind me here it is still an active
scene at the shopping center off of
Spring Mountain we actually just saw a
SWAT vehicle leave the area a short time
ago now sources tell our 8 news now
investigators that suspect again
connected to a homicide from earlier
today was killed in this police shooting
sources also say that suspect was
holding a person he knew hostage at the
time of the shooting but that person is
reportedly now safe you can see this
appears to have happened in this
shopping center again along Spring
Mountain the entire parking lot is still
blocked off and should be for a while
longer as police continue this
investigation neither don't appear to be
any significant road closures or traffic
tie-ups as a result of this other than a
few neighborhood streets now back out
here live police are still asking people
to avoid this direct area as they
continue this investigation we're also
expecting to hear from officers get an
update in more details as to exactly
what happened so stay with eight news
now of course online and on air tomorrow
for the latest updates reporting live
tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now